hey guys welcome to a brand new video uh
today I was kind of looking through my
giant [__] folder of video clips of
images of stuff I've done over the last
year and a bit and I was kind of
thinking of everything I've recorded
what are the best uh flips that I've
done now keep in mind that for a lot of
this I was still learning I don't have
um billions of GP at the most I've had
is 100 Mil honestly I just haven't been
dedicated enough to actually growing my
cash deck so keep that in mind but here
are the top 10 flips that I've done uh
some of them are from about a year ago a
lot of them are from more recently or
from when Master Clues and raids came
out uh so a couple little Throwbacks
there and yeah let's go have a look okay
so coming in at number 10 just a nice
and simple uh free-to-play flip of
guilded boots uh we got a 270k margin on
those but we did flip four of those
uh for a
176k profit uh not bad for number 10 I
still to this day do this item and I'm
pretty sure this particular image was
from a couple weeks ago so consistently
a good item to flip coming in at number
nine is the ring of nature another free
to- playay item and I still think this
is one of the most expensive free
to-play items only outdone by The Ring
of coins unless something's changed
recently uh managed to get a 440k margin
on each one of these given this a 1.3
mil profit pretty good especially for
free to play uh coming in at number
eight is actually just a nice simple
flip of the infinity hat I kind of
locked out here and this is a very inm
Market heavily traded item and I still
managed to get a 1.4 mil profit on that
which is extremely good uh at least I
think anyway just a nice simple flip but
good nonetheless coming in at number
seven is the elder chaos Hood now this
is right around the time when it was
coming into the game so actually just
about a year go I think the update came
out on August 11th and yeah it was a
very expensive item when it first came
out but of course has dropped in price
we manag to get a
1.5 mil profit on this item with only
flipping five of them at the time this
is extremely good for me cuz I really
didn't have more than 10 or 15 mil to
work with so getting like 10% of my
money back uh was extremely good okay
coming in at number six is actually a
flip of the Twisted buckler so the
Twisted buckler was released with uh r
and this was pretty much around the time
that they uh were coming out so in
February uh we got a 1.6 mil profit off
of just one of them I think this is day
two after they were released the first
day I got an even better flip which
should be coming up a little bit later
uh but yeah this is the most profitable
item that I could afford uh cuz all the
raid items were going for uh 80 mil plus
I only had about 50 mil to work with I
was buying Dragon swords uh dragon
throwing axes all sorts of stuff that I
could afford but this was definitely my
most profitable flip uh well except for
one other coming in at number five is
actually once again another free to-
play item a very profitable flip for the
monks robe top G uh we got about a
637k margin on this and flipping three
of these gives us about 1.9 mil in
profit uh really happy with how this is
probably this is probably my most
profitable free to playay flip of all
time I don't think I would have
forgotten a clip like this before uh I
think this was the best margin I have
ever gotten on a free to- playay item
that wasn't kind of just a fluke or
something random happening this was I
managed to flip three of the item in a
day for a 600k profit that's like a bond
almost right there uh just on these
three items okay take that back uh the
Ring of coins is actually free to play
so the next one up is actually a ring of
coin flip uh where I got over a mil 1
mil profit on one of the Rings given
this a 2.2 mil profit again in free to
play just from two items just CU to show
that free to play flipping really isn't
that much worse if you got the money
anyway you could argue there's no point
of actually staying free to play but
that's for another day coming in at
number three is the ale of the Gods now
this was around the time when Master
Clues were coming out uh the prices were
fluctuating a lot on the first three you
can see I got an 800k margin uh the last
two only 600k but in total we got 2.5 m
just off of this one transaction uh
which at the time and now is still uh
one of my best flips of all time coming
in at number two is another Twisted
buckler flip now this is the one I
bought on day one probably one of the
more risky things I've ever done with my
money uh cuz if you go look at the price
now it's all the way down to 16 mil but
even at the time it was fluctuating up
and down up and down but I did manage to
sell it off and it's probably the
highest amount I've gotten on a singular
item uh but still not my best flip of
all time and coming in at number one my
best flip of all time is the hku sock
surprisingly enough this one just kind
of came out of nowhere I ended up buying
five pairs of anku socks uh for 6.8 mil
and I sold them all for
7.7 uh so that is almost a 1 mil profit
on each singular item and a total that
is a 4.5 mil flip easily my best flip of
all time all right guys that's it uh so
you can kind of see that I'm not the
richest person obviously or the really
best flipper or mercher for that matter
uh but I did get some pretty decent
flips over the course of this last year
and yeah so my question to you guys what
is your best flip of all time leave a
comment down below and if you did enjoy
the video don't forget to toss a like
and I will see you guys in the next
video
n
[Music]